[Alkış]
hoş geldiniz
hayata bazı olma halleri bazı şeyleri
bekleme halleri
insanda Bazı duygular oluşturuyor
Aslında günlerde olduğu gibi
bugün gelse diye insan çok söylenir
Nitekim Aslında endüstri devriminden
önce haftanın ilk günü Pazar pazardan
geliyor çarşı pazar gezmek insanlarla
sosyalleşmek ama endüstri devrildikten
sonra tüm dünyada Pazartesi günü haftada
başlangıç günü olarak kabul ediliyor
Günah Keçisi Pazartesi günü
birçok insan aslında hangi günü daha çok
seviyor kendi içinde bunun bir cevabını
verebilir sizin de düşündüğünüzü
zannediyorum yapılan araştırmalar en
sevilen gün konusunda cuma gününü
gösteriyor
cevap aslında bana şunu sorgulatıyor
şunu düşündürüyor
yaşamak
güzel bir şey yaşamaz aslında bir zaman
geçirmek bir şeyi başlamak ve devam
ettirmek bu cevap Aslında bitişi
sevgimizi göster
çalışmaktan kurtulduğumuz tatile doğru
gittiğimiz bir şeyi seviyoruz yani
cumadan önceki 5 günü biraz hiçe
sayıyoruz Ben pazartesi günü çok
seviyorum En sevdiğim gün Pazartesi günü
Neden Çünkü
başlangıçta bana güç veriyor bunu Babur
burada çay simit sohbet programını
yaptığımız belki ikinci üçüncü yılda
hissetmeye başladım
Nitekim bu sabah buraya gelmeden önce
otelin lobisinde Armağan bey ve Yasemin
Hanım var sizin dedim En sevdiğiniz gün
hangisi Armağan bey dedi ki Cumartesi
günü
Yasemin Hanım Pazartesi dedi Allah'ım
dedim bana benziyor
sevindim ardından Armağan bey dedi ki
Yasemin Hanım Hep pazartesi günleri izin
şimdi
pazartesi sendromu diye bir şey var
Sonuç olarak yakın çevremde de bunu
duyuyorum şahit oluyor pazartesi
sendromu Aslında Pazar günü saat böyle
3D 4 arasında insanların içinde böyle
kıpır kıpır yapmaya başladı araştırmalar
sonucunda ortaya çıkmış
bazı insanlarda da pazartesi sabahı daha
da yoğun bir şekilde hissediliyor tatil
bitiyor ertesi gün trafik var iş var
Yapılacak bir sürü şey var
Yani pazartesi size bir atlatalım durumu
insanların çoğunluğunda gözleniyor
Herkes o pazar günü o sendromu yaşarken
benim için aslında
önünüzdeki hafta içerisinde yapacağı ele
heyecanlandıracak Bana iyi gelecek
rutinlerimi düzenleme planlama zamanı
temel olarak yıllar geçtikçe fark
ediyorum ki Aslında ben çalışmaya pazar
günü başlıyorum elimde kalem önümde Not
Defteri pazar Akşamları
pazartesiden bir sonraki kadar pazarı ya
cevap bile geçiriyorum
süreç içerisinde
o motivasyonla yapma heyecanı da
birlikte Yaşadığımız bir ekibimiz var
uzun yıllardır birlikte çalışıyoruz
onları gözlemliyorum ve burada
chelsea'daki sohbet süreci içerisinde
bir dönemde şöyle bir karar verme
sürecine girdi bunu da iki
arkadaşlarınla paylaşmıştır
akşam çıkıyoruz yoğun bir hayat
kadınların kişisel bakımını yaptırması
saç makyaj kuaför bile 3-4 saat bu insan
eşiyle sevgilisiyle görüşecek biraz
yalnız kalması lazım haliyle çok yoğun
bir tempo içerisinde olduklarını gördük
ben birazcık daha şanslıyım kendi
rütbelerim daha farklıydı Arkadaşlar
bir izledim Bir hafta tatil yapsak onu
dediler çok güzel çok iyi gelir dedim
her ay bir hafta tatil yapalım nasıl
dediler
[Müzik]
4 haftada yazacağımız şey 3 haftada
yapalım Her ayın sonunda da biz
tatilim Bu kulağa çok çekici deniliyordu
onların gözlerindeki parlamayı gerçekten
hatırlıyor ve biz o söylediğim şeyi
denemeye başladık birazdan işte iki
haftada geçti 3 haftaya geçti son hafta
tatile giriyoruz çok güzel Keyfimiz
yerinde dinleniyoruz insanlar tatile
gitme heyecanı içerisinde ikinci el
çalıştık çalıştık üçüncü hafta yine
Tatildeyiz
İçinizde bir şeyler oluşmaya başlıyor
Ama üçüncü ay geldik yavaş yavaş böyle
bir insanlar tatil olsa da ofise gelme
ihtiyacı içindeler aslında tatiliz
sürekli yaptığımız şeyler Neyse biz uyuz
Aslında
mükemmelliyetçilik dediğimiz şey dedi
Eylem değil bir alışkanlık 11 yıldır hiç
ara vermeden sezon arası vermedik
düzenli bir şekilde her hafta bir ünlü
isimde ve burada buluşma heyecanla bizim
en büyük rutinimiz olmuştur
bu projeyi başlarken de haftalık olsun
kendimi çok yıpratmayın ekibi çok
yıpratmayalım Çünkü dizilerde sinemada
çok yoğun çalışılıyor herkes Aslında bu
şikayetçilik içerisinde İşini yapmaya
çalışıyor koşarak tatile gidiyor yaşamda
bu şekilde dönüyor
şunu farkettik Biz aslında bizi iyi hale
getiren şey tatil değil dedik Güneş
demiyoruz tatil yapıyoruz boş Zaman
geçiriyoruz Salı günü buluşuruz Çarşamba
buluşuruz tatil dediğimiz şey zaten
maliyetli de bir şey yavaş yavaş
çadırlamalar başladı aslında bizi diziye
yapılan şey ürettiğimiz kendimizi iyi
hale getiren şey başarımız insan
ilişkimiz burada şahsiyetini sohbette
haftanın ortasında yapacağımız bir çekim
için el fenerinde Daha Pazar gününden o
heyecanı yaş çekim gününü bekliyoruz
montajı izliyoruz yayını bekliyoruz
pazar günü yayına da ve bu 11 yıldır
böyle sürüyor kendi hayatım açısından
bazen insan aslında
sevildiği şeyi bulamama hali içerisinde
çırpınır durur haliyle pazartesi
sendromu yaşayan insanlarda ki
araştırmada şunu söylüyor bu insanlar
için ne kadar seviyor dünyada işini
severek yapan insan sayısı yüzde beşi
geçmiş bu çok ciddi bir rakam çok kaygı
verici bir rakam haliyle Bu yüzde beşlik
içinde olma durumu
kendiliğinden oluşan bir şey değildir
Sonuç olarak
şahsa bağlı bir şey değil Çünkü şans
dediğimiz şey vardır ve bu günle
alakalıdır diye düşünüyorum ama
bir hafta dediğimiz şey bir hayat
dediğimiz şey bir planlama ile ilgilidir
O yüzden insan hayatının temelini ve o
insana karakteriyle o insana yaşam
şeklini belirleyen şey de rutinlerdir
yani kendi belirli dediğimiz
istekleri yaptığımız devam ettiğimiz
rutinlerimiz bizimdirler
menümüzde bir hafta içerisinde
düşünürsek bir sonraki haftaya menüde
neler var Hangi rutinlerimiz var bu
rutinleri aslında hep geliştirmeye
çalıştım çünkü
şu anki konuşmada olduğu gibi bu bir
deneyim hayatında bir defa iki defa
yapılabilecek bir süreç bir
heyecan Ama siz bunu bir rutin haline
dönüştürmeye başladığımızda O
hayatınızın bir parçası oluyor o zaman
bir konuşmacı olabilirsiniz
bir sunucu olabilirsiniz O yüzden burada
olmak güzel ya da geçtiğimiz haftalarda
farklı bir dansa gitmişti Afrika dansına
Evet onu deneyimledim çok güzeldi ama
rutinim haline henüz gelmedi Her
perşembe akşamı dansa gitme haline geçme
durumu ve ondan zevk alma durumu artık
otomatikman
yeniden Ne yapsam sorusunu sormadan
planlı bir şekilde perşembe akşamları
Ben gidiyorum
Cuma Sabahları spora gidiyor cumartesi
günü ailemle geçiyor Pazar günü kız
arkadaşımıza
tatilin son günü ile yaşıyorum şeklinde
bir planlama insana ister istemez Bir
boşlukta olmama halinde getirecek
tir değer olarak o ritimleri sevmek
gerekiyor çünkü
sevmediği bir şeyi yapmadığı için
Aslında bugün sizleri karşısındayım
sevmediğim şeyleri yapmamak Belki bir
çocuk Bunu duyunca ben de istemiyorum
Bunu yapmak istemiyorum onu gücünü
alacağım ben hiçbir zaman sevmediklerine
yönelmedim hep sevdiğim şeyleri yani
program içerisinde bana sorulan
şeylerden biri doğruydu en çok hangi
konuda olan sohbetten zevk alamazsın
Zaten ben hepsini severek yaptım o
yüzden bu Sevdikten beride kaldığınızda
ve bu sevgi şeflerinin içinde güzel
rutinler koyduğumuzda İyi ve sağlıklı
bir yaşam sürebiliyorsunuz İyi ve
sağlıklı yaşam nedir
bizi Aslında İyi hissettiren şey yine
severek yaptığımız sürekli yaptığımız
rutinlerle diyor çünkü
karşıdaki
şimdi
şu arkamda görmüş olduğunuz Aslında
Hepimizin bir anı bekleme hali var ya Ya
şu parayı bir çözebilirsek çok iyi
olacak
bana bir evet de siz hayatım değişecek
yani mutsuzluk hali içerisinde devam
ettiğini süreçlere dikkat ederseniz bir
şey olma halinde Çok bekleme hali vardır
cumartesi gelse de ya bugünü yaşıyoruz
Daha uykum bitmedi bekleme halde ki
buraya gelmeden önce şu
bir an önce burada olma isteği vardı
sonra aslında kendi kendime düşündüğünde
Aslında Hayat
bekleme haline nasıl
değerlendirdiğimizle alakalı
bir şey Kime göre bekliyoruz bekleme
halinden zevk alma durumu önemli bir
duygudur Çünkü
sabır vardır içerisinde plan vardır ve o
bekleme hali hayatın içerisinde bir
gerçektir diye düşünüyor vapurda
içerisine sohbet programı 11 yıldır
ekranlarda
izleyicilere teşekkür ediyorum ama fikir
İyi ki aklıma geldikten sonra 5 yıl
sürmüştü ilk televizyon ekranına çıktığı
süreç için 5 yıl içerisinde neler neler
oldu
belirleme süreci bir ilaç süreci Aslında
Yaratanın tanrının bizi diğerlerinden
diğer canlılardan farklı kıldığı akılla
planlama ile alakalı bir şey tabi
hayvanlara da bu konuda
Hayret etmemek onlar da beni şaşkınla
uğratıyorlar o yüzden doğadan da
esinlenmek boğanın ritminden de fayda
sağlamak gerekiyor
evet pazartesi omzumuzu aldık yavaş
yavaş çıkmaya başlıyoruz ve Aslında
Ondan sonra en keyifli andayız duygusu
var
Peki beni Cuma günü nasıl geçiyor
herkesin en sevdiği gün cumayken pazar
günü şunu yapalım Burada yapalım şununla
toplantı yapman lazım bunu ziyaret etmem
gerekiyor şuraya gitmem lazım şuna bir
çözüm getirmem lazım evde yapılacak
şunlar var listesi önümde durduğu için
cuma günü ben onunla yüzleşiyorum
aslında
herkes haftaya bitirdik derken ben de
biraz böyle ya yine olmadı ya
başardığım zamanlar oluyor ama kendi
motivasyonumu sağladığım şey ben neleri
yapmak istiyorum
neleri
yapabildiğim kısmı ile alakalı
yine bir pazar geliyor yine geçtiğimiz
haftadan olan yapılmış ve yapılmamış
şeylerle yola devam ediyoruz aslında
bir hafta dünyadaki imzamız gibi bir şey
sonuçlara bir yerden başlıyoruz ve onu
tamamlıyoruz tekrar pazartesi salı
çarşamba perşembe cuma geliyor Orada da
bir imza atıyoruz O yüzden taklit
edilememek
için orijinal yaşamak gerekiyor
uzun yıllardır programımızın içinde
üzerinde olan bir rutinle konuşmamızı da
tamamlamak isterim
bazen bazı şeyler bir kere iyi gelir bir
daha iyi gelir sonra o iyi gelen şeyi
başkasından duymaya başlarsınız
gelişinizi güle güle gidişiniz güle güle
Her işiniz güle güle olsun inşallah
diyerek teşekkür ediyoruz
Hani süreden erken bitirdiğim için biraz
daha kalayım dedim kaç dakika